alger 1er juillet 1992 les algériens
conduise sa dernière demeure le
président mohamed boudiaf qui viennent
d'être assassinée
dans l'hommage spontané que lui rend la
foule notamment les jeunes se perçoit la
colère contre un système discréditer
l'autre des politiciens accusé de
corruption mais aussi la peur du vide
l'angoissé longuement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
il disait en arabe
boudiaf est mort il laisse un message
la jeunesse arrivent et fera le
nécessaire par aoun membre du haut
comité d'état avocat ministre des droits
de l'homme en 1991
[Applaudissements]
à mort assassin à vous les habitués et
puis vous faites semblant de pleurer ou
fait que vous êtes crocodile et vous les
suivez c'est vous le suivi est une
comédie c'est inadmissible c'est encore
une insulte et alors on nous avait pris
pour des gens qui étaient les ennemis de
boudiaf et qui en plus pour se camoufler
faisait semblant de pleurer sa mort mais
djebbar conseiller de mohamed boudiaf
[Musique]
je sentais que c'était c'était foutu
c'est à dire que
qu'on allait réellement très dans la
confrontation
que vraiment
sa lettre la guerre
malika abdelaziz journalistes
[Musique]
vous y avez été populaire le jour où il
a été assassiné parce que les gens ont
se sont aperçus qu'il avait été
assassiné pour des raisons bien précises
jean audibert ambassadeur de france à
alger de 1989 à 1992
la société algérienne n'a pas encore
fini de payer les conséquences de
l'assassinât de mohamed boudiaf ahmed
ben naoum
sociologue
[Musique]
six mois plus tôt le 16 janvier 1992
c'était un homme seul qui était rappelé
à alger un homme oublié un inconnu pour
la jeunesse algérienne
c'est le coma et sayed ahmad afzali
wahaha d'habitat ou la voilà et c'est le
match des side story war ar coum à waâda
des nabots battait sa mine feljas
chinois pamiers charlie wolf raïs funky
pas aux ardennes menace départ très bas
[Musique]
hassan ahmed boudiaf
télévision bada
nonchalante comment tout l'univers du
montant de
la cagnotte
l'accord s'est fait sur son nom pour
éviter le pire certains avaient vu en
lui la caution qui leur permettrait de
garder leur pouvoir boudiaf lui revenait
pour redresser le pays le différend
remonter à l'époque de la guerre
d'indépendance
[Musique]
doublé en algérie ou en plusieurs
endroits du territoire une série
d'attentats ont été commis dans la nuit
qui passait dans la toussaint c'est
boudiaf qui joue le rôle décisif dans la
création du front de libération
nationale qui le 1er novembre 1954
déclenché l'insurrection
leur effet la magie lutte les armes à la
main c'est l'action qui soude les
militants d'origines diverses en deux
ans le fln dans une lutte sans merci
roue qui a le monopole du mouvement
révolutionnaire il parvient à élargir la
lutte et tient en échec l'armée
française qui doit mobiliser le
contingent l'avion de ben bella et de
ses compagnons avaient des bébés tournée
et dans la cour d'une prison d'alger
benbella mois mais il erre à iba même
ben dhia et l'achève en octobre 1956
regardons les actualités françaises
les algériens découvrent pour la
première fois le visage des dirigeants
clandestins du mouvement au lieu où diaf
en 1962 après huit ans de guerre
l'algérie accède à l'indépendance aux
termes des accords d'evian le gpr à
gouvernement provisoire de la république
algérienne ton boudiaf et membres
entrent dans alger en liesse et tout
fait durant les combats les dissensions
entre dirigeants éclate en plein jour
dans les conférences de presse il
devient impossible de parler d'une seule
voix ces entretiens et city se sont
déroulées dans une atmosphère
fraternité et de compréhension
ce budget maintenant par la parole le
peuple algérien attend beaucoup de sa
récente victoire
puissions nous la lui concrétisé en lui
donnant les moyens de se prononcer
librement et le plus tôt serait le mieux
je travaillais de s'instruire en géorgie
enfin débarrassé du spectacle atik
nature et qu'on soit obligé pour la tête
politique j'ai confiance à l'avenir de
mon public laquelle confiance repose
avant tout sur le peuple libre
en septembre l'armée des frontières
commandé par le coût de l'aide du
médiane marche sur alger et tranchent en
faveur de benbella gpr à doit s'effacer
au riollet du prestige d'une victoire
qui revient avant tout aux peuples
l'armée s'impose pour longtemps comme
l'indispensable piliers du pouvoir
boudiaf s'élèvent contre ce qu'ils
considèrent comme et dérives de la
révolution en juillet 1963 il est enlevé
et restera emprisonné quatre mois
on l'a accusé vous avez entendu la
nouvelle à l'assemblée on l'accusé sans
l'accusé enfin par allusion en tout cas
je vais faire partie d'un complot contre
la sûreté de l'état
pensez pas croyons pas
au mariage 15e temps il est militant
depuis 20 ans et je ne pense pas qu'ils
puissent se compliquer
il n'aimait pas monsieur ben bella
et vous pensez qu'il faut des motifs
comme en politique qu'il a été arrêté
c'est qu'en fait il n'avait aucune
activité révolutionnaire ou clandestine
et arrêtez vous dire parce qu'il ya des
agissements que justin est dangereux
besoin
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention de
calais dépôt pense à chaque coin de rue
en septembre 1963 la constitution
adoptée par référendum consacre la place
du fln en tant que parti unique dans un
régime de type présidentiel
kendall un seul candidat est élu à la
présidence il n'en sera écartée en 1965
tout par un coup d'état du colonel by
media
je vais vous demander ce que les
étudiants pensent de ce qui s'est passé
à alger ces pompiers c'est pour la
télévision france fait l'édition
française génère je peux vous dire que
les étudiants ils passent beaucoup de
mal ce qui se passe et là vous
considérez que cette prise de pouvoir du
colonel actionnaire qu'est ce que ça
veut dire réactionnaire typiquement
fasciste par la manière dont ça s'est
fait
fascistes dans la manière mais peut-être
pas fasciste dans les télécoms sa part
au machiniste dans la manière les
prolongements obligatoirement suivre les
chefs historiques devenus opposants sont
peu à peu éliminées
boudiaf contrainte à l'exil durant l'été
1964 finira par s'installer au maroc son
nom disparaît de l'histoire officielle
son image et effacer les années
boumédiène en dépit de la dictature qui
interdit l'expression de toute
opposition sont des années d'espoir
certains disent pour que la révolution
soit pur il faut qu'elle soit laïc c'est
pas tout à fait quand je suce pas tout à
fait d'accord
c'est pas tout à fait d'accord c'est
cette définition il ne faut pas
remplacer d'anciens en fait pas de
nouveaux prophètes à choisir je le dis
toujours dit
notre prophète
entre
et de nouveaux prêts autre fait
mal sur ne s'impose maintenant
la tâche de leurs pour le pouvoir c'est
la construction de la nation algérienne
tout ce qui est susceptible de menacer
l'unité de la communauté est écarté
l'islam considéré comme composante la
nation algérienne devient religion de
l'état
à sa mort en décembre
1978 vous médias nous laisse à son
successeur le colonel chadli un pays
miné par la bureaucratie et la trop
grande centralisation de son économie
de son exil marocain boudiaf sollicité
par la télévision française dresse un
bilan sévère les hommes qui sont au
pouvoir sont pas nombreux ils sont
entourés de secret ledit libération ne
sont pas connues et cela fait que les
gens qui s'entendent hors du sérail non
pas les possibilités réellement de
prévoir ce qui peut se passer demain ce
qui est certain c'est que aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose à l'algérie c'est
de savoir où c'est la continuité ou
c'est le changement à il existe des
fausses en algérie qui sont pour le
changement au niveau des syndicats au
niveau des étudiants au niveau des
femmes au niveau de l'immigration
qui est kate qui se posent des problèmes
je pense que ça rapporte de force il
faut le renforcer parce que la solution
aujourd'hui pour l'algérie ne peut être
qu'une issue démocratique
durant les années 80 la transition
amorcée vers une économie de marché se
traduit par une cure d'austérité
socialement et politiquement explosive
la réforme santé ne font qu'attiser le
mécontentement et les inquiétudes d'une
population qui craint de perdre les
avantages que le système lui assurer
l'emploi à toi des produits alimentaires
de base à bon marché
les jeunes premières victimes du chômage
déclenché des émeutes dont plusieurs
villes du pays
sur fond d'un culture économique
d'ignorance économique du pouvoir de
l'époque c'est-à-dire du pouvoir de
chedly
sur fond de gabegie de déstructuration
de l'économie de destruction de tout ce
qui avait été construit dans la douleur
et bien le jeu politique a consisté à
monter les islamistes contre les
modernistes et bien octobre 88 a été
provoqué dans des parle pas un jeu de
pouvoir de clans du pouvoir sans que ses
clients ne s'aperçoivent que ça allait
avoir ça ne provoque un séisme dans la
société
[Applaudissements]
ces émeutes révèleront jours l'ampleur
de la crise
là on est populaire qui le pouvaient ont
fait appel ouvre le flanc le bilan
officiel fait état de 159 morts
l'image de l'armée au sein de la
jeunesse ne sera plus jamais la même
mais il y avait eu avant
at-il précurseur si je puis dire des
émeutes localisées forte à constantine à
oran plus l'agitation pays kabyle à tizi
ouzou dans les années 80 donc ce n'était
pas un événement complètement cette
explosion populaire de d'octobre 88
n'était pas complètement inattendu ce
avait été précédée par des secousses
local
éric maillet jara
après octobre 88 après la réforme de la
constitution
il fallait marquer d'une façon
ostensible que ont changé de système
alors c'est à peu près la même période
que l'armée est sorti du fln donc avant
le comité directeur du fln il y avait un
tiers de militaires qui faisaient la loi
dans donc l'armée est sorti
officiellement après un discours du
parti ex parti unique et on a nommé le
chef d'état-major ministre de la défense
ce qui était une espèce de normalisation
on se préparait à cette mutation est à
ce changement à partir d'un système qui
était un système bureaucratique
centralisée
de de pouvoir économique d'état et qu'on
allait donc vers quelque chose qui
allait introduire un peu de souplesse
dans dans dans la vie politique dans la
vie sociale
bonsoir la chaîne iii fidèle à sa
tradition d'ouverture et vous analysez
les
voies la démocratisation de la ville que
vit notre pays
l'événement est important je dirais même
qu'il s'agit d'une révolution puisque
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'algérie indépendante des sensibilités
différentes s'expriment en
liberté sur les antennes d'une radio et
puis il ya des lois de 89 qui décide que
pour créer un parti politique il faut
être quinze personnes
alors effectivement en algérie
fleurissent
je sais pas combien parti politique
c'est pas des partis politiques des
forces et des associations à caractère
politique
c'est pas un problème de rhétorique un
parti politique ça signifie créer un
parti politique ça signifie avoir un
congrès constitutif un programme affiché
une direction inconnue un règlement
intérieur un certain nombre de militants
connus chez nous on fait l'économie de
tout ça vous fait l'économie de tout ça
ça donne quoi donc ça donne des partis
politiques qui se constituent sur la
base de 15 adhérents qui ont des
programmes qui sont pas connues
parfois ils en ont pas du tout
et ça permet dans cette espèce de magma
général de faire passer la
reconnaissance d'un parti islamiste qui
en l'occurrence c'est le fils bien que
la constitution est prévu qu'aucun parti
ne pouvait avoir j'irai une base
idéologique fondée sur la religion bon
malgré malgré ces dispositions
constitutionnelles le fils a été
reconnue et donc c'était un parti nous
il est clair que la légalisation du fils
s'est fait sur intervention personnelle
du président chadli pour qu'il ya un
vrai multipartisme il faut qu'ils aient
dissolution du front
ce que dans le front tel qu'il existait
en 88 au moment de l'explosion et après
on savait très bien qu'il y avait
différentes sensibilités puisqu'on y
avait des crypto communiste et il y
avait des barbes fln bons qu'ils étaient
les islamistes les cryptes aux
islamistes abassi madani leaders du fis
sait on ce cadre du fln ne se satisfait
pas d'un islam religion de l'état il
veut passer à la république islamique
la politique n'a pas un parti qui
par jour le faisons avec la prière
les opposants historiques à épargner des
bonnes valeurs invité à légaliser leur
parti regagné alger
[Musique]
boudiaf quant à lui demeure sceptique et
préfère se tenir à l'écart
mondialisée que après 88 on on a
organisé un vide politique
et se vident effectivement à
l'atomisation c'est un vide politique
parce que quand il ya cinquante mille
partie on sait pas de 14 ans qui sont
ils peuvent raconter n'importe quoi on
sait pas c'est une espèce de vide
politique qui va favoriser un parti
politique qui lui a une stratégie et qui
sait ce qu'il veut qui est le fils
le fait du jour c'est la victoire des
islamistes lors des élections locales en
algérie si l'on en croit les premières
estimations le front islamique de salut
l'emporterait dans la plupart des
grandes villes là fallait-il ou pas
légaliser le fils un débat qu'on aurait
pu avoir le droit de mener dans notre
pays c'est un problème important qui
concerne tout le monde arabe faut-il ou
non légalisés dans un cadre
constitutionnel république des
mouvements qui se réclament d'une autre
logique que la logique républicaine
qui se réclament d'une autre logique que
suffrage universel puisque le conseil
la souveraineté populaire puisqu'il
considère que la souveraineté c'est
celle de dieu le chef du fils le disait
le vote la démocratie c'est un pis mais
nous votons pour pouvoir éliminer la
démocratie c'est ça le fils on voit
beaucoup dans le fils la jeunesse qui
les a suivis les jeunes perdus des
quartiers tous ces jeunes qui voulaient
être existé qui voulait être c'était
très impressionnant d'ailleurs ces
jeunes qui voulaient être non être
présent
à la diamond
league yann et fille cool note alan
apprend le nom d'îles stifter gilles
stievenart jab wihda bank échappe god we
dance
et badens et de rased dooley
le discours des islamistes est
essentiellement justicialiste et se sert
exclusivement de l'émotion provoquée par
l'injustice des pouvoirs en place
en décidant d'organiser des élections
législatives en décembre 1991 le pouvoir
au front office la possibilité de
parvenir à ses fins
[Applaudissements]
jade y étaient soumis à la presse soumis
à la pression du front islamique du
salut qui demandait le plus rapidement
possible des élections légistatives et
même des présidentielles
[Applaudissements]
hommage à maurice
sybille habib el
adli est binaire
la jolie
abassi madani
[Applaudissements]
l'armée fait une déclaration
litoria delwiche sort carnegie c'est la
revue de l'armée disent en clair jamais
on permettra à l'intégrisme prendre le
pouvoir en algérie malgré ça on va aux
élections grande première démocratique
en algérie avec les premières élections
pluralistes organisées depuis 62 depuis
l'indépendance auparavant les députés
était élu sur une liste unique du fln
cette fois les 13 millions et demi
d'électeurs inscrits peuvent choisir
parmi cinq mille 700 candidats
représentant au total 49 parties il y
avait toute une partie de l'état major
politique et de l'armée qui était
persuadé à la suite d'informations
qu'ils avaient recueilli de sondages
qu'ils avaient fait que
le front islamique de salut
aux élections législatives ne ferait pas
plus du tiers des sièges de l'assemblée
qui aurait donc un gros tiers fils un
petit tiers a fait laine et puis un
petit un dernier petit tiers pour parler
comme marius
avec des kabyles des mozabites des
mouvements divers intérêts que tout ça
permettrait de faire des alliances
politiques
oui bonsoir et bien donc vous avez les
résultats sont pas des résultats
définitifs les résultats officiels
annoncés par le conseil constitutionnel
il y à peu près à la moitié des sièges
un peu plus qu'ils ont été enlevés au
premier tour et on constate que le score
réalisé par le fait c'est très important
on savait que s'il y avait un deuxième
tour le front islamique de salut avait
de façon inéluctable les deux tiers de
la majorité de l'assemblée et donc
pouvez modifier la constitution par un
vote il y amène la nécessité d'une
riposte au danger que représente la
mainmise du fils sur l'assemblée
nationale et la cohabitation chaque
dimanche qui avant les élections a
annoncé qu'il était tout à fait prêt à
diriger l'algérie avec un autre parti
que les faits il n'y a pas lieu de
s'inquiéter outre mesure le fils est un
est un phénomène important grave mais je
pense que l'algérie est très loin d'être
l'iran
ait ahmed tient avant tout à conforter
au second tour les bons résultats
enregistrés par son parti le ffs
national le front des forces socialistes
bien sûr de mobiliser cet électorat qui
s'est largement abstenus au premier tour
des élections mais c'est aussi sa façon
à lui de lancer un message au pouvoir
pas question de remettre en cause le
processus démocratique dans la presse
française certaines pannes française on
a dit le ffs appelle à la poursuite du
processus électoral
bon mais en réalité ce n'est pas perçu
comme ça du tout c'était c'était plutôt
une manifestation populaire pour
l'instauration de la démocratie mais
dans les gens qui ont manifesté j'en
connaissais beaucoup il y en avait
autant qu'ils étaient pour la poursuite
que que ce qu'était pour l'interruption
parce qu'après que aït ahmed et appelé à
cette grande manifestation
il y en a d'autres qui ce qu'ils ont
appelé à la manifestation
mais avec d'autres objectifs dont il ya
eu benhamouda il ya eu çà a dit et eux
ils avaient constitué entre temps le
comité de défense de la république qui
demandait l'arrêt du processus électoral
et tout ça à manifester ensemble deux
jours après nous avons tenu un conseil
de gouvernement
est vraiment c'était mortel c'était un
conseil je sais pas tu es une veillée
mortuaire
c'était complètement surréaliste que
parce que
parmi les mythologies algérienne il y a
les mythes français qui jouent un rôle
important et donc moi je me souviens des
ministres qui me disais mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils auraient pas une
cohabitation entre
shalit et les e-services il ya bien eu
la cohabitation entre mitterrand et
chirac c'est pareil qu'aux peut-être
problème c'est quand même bien une
nuance enfin faut alors lorsqu'on a
terminé la la réunion
le chef du gouvernement n'avait pris
aucune décision
je me suis approché de lui jeudi mais
enfin quelles décisions at-on prise de
patente le compte à rebours a commencé à
tourner et
il me dit oui oui et rallye d'alsace
ministre de la défense
général major un an dans le système
algérien
excessivement important il me dit moi je
vais désigné deux personnes c'est à dire
deux généraux
vous deux civils et deux généraux vous
allez vous réunir et dites-nous étudier
le problème
alors qu'elles étaient les possibilités
pour arrêter le processus électoral
première possibilité dire à l'armée
stopper lé sort ses chars et d'y aller
je ne reconnais pas c'est le coup d'état
claire
deuxième possibilité
prévoir que le président de la
république démissionne avant le deuxième
tour pourquoi parce que la constitution
prévoit
que en cas de démission du président ou
des décès ou de vacance du pouvoir on
doit dans les 45 jours
procéder aux élections
présidentielles
l'armée contre un choix de vie à se
retirer
la démission du président algérien
chadli bendjedid émission annoncé tout à
l'heure en direct à la télévision
algérienne et j'espère
que l'opinion publique algérienne sera
apprécié sa de responsabilité sa
décision
je ne cherche pas à fuir mes
responsabilités bien au contraire mais
sa décision me semble indispensable vu
la difficulté la gravité de cette étape
particulière une position de la france
était de réserve tout à fait
c'est trop tôt pour prendre position
c'est à dire que
président de la république française a
été un peu
cette histoire de l'art et du processus
avait été très très mal perçu en europe
et en particulier en france
ce qui ne pas été accompli en cette
circonstance et jusqu'au terme prévu
devra l'être
et que les dirigeants algériens se
noueront en retrouvant le fils
de la démocratisation nécessaire qui
passe forcément par des élections libres
je viens en france où je vois le membre
du cabinet de mitterrand
j'essaye d'expliquer
ça ne passe pas
en tant que ministre des droits de
l'homme
je considère que
lorsqu'une situation
exceptionnelle se présente pour la vie
d'un petit et qu'il s'agit à ce moment
là de défendre tout ce pape est parce
que ce qui nous menace et nous après le
15 janvier
c'était l'état islamique tel qu'il est
conçu dans certains pays que je ne veux
pas nommer ici ce que j'ai constaté à
cette époque là c'est que dans les pays
où on comprenait les motifs profonds de
l'arrêt du processus électoral en
algérie le l'intégrisme islamiste ne
trouvaient plus tellement de de
compréhension par contre dans les autres
pays eh bien il a continué à s'installer
et à se développer
donc là on le mont ce soir après après
le départ de cette vie on savait pas
encore très bien qu'ils allaient qu'est
ce qui allait advenir
donc il a fallu attendre le 13 la
réunion du conseil national de sécurité
haut comité d'état est créé à la hâte
pour éviter une vacance du pouvoir mais
il lui faut aussi un président qui soit
un symbole fort un soir vers 11 heures
minuit nous disent nous sommes à quatre
nous discutons et puis jeudi el hadji
qui m'écoutent
et si on demandait à boudiaf devenir un
outil bien sûr ce serait merveilleux
mais
je ne veux pas accepter quand il a eu au
téléphone
il a dit j'aimerais venir te voir
sa réaction ça a été pourquoi il a dit
fox il faut que je te vois absolument il
a dit si c'est pour encore une histoire
de partie parce que c'était les
créations des partis à l'appel à ce
moment là il a dit si c'est pour une
histoire de partie je ne veux rien
savoir je suis observateur de loin
jeûneurs
alors il a insisté il a dit bon tu n'as
qu'à venir il ya une dîme et non c'est
pas possible
alors au bout d'une heure de discussions
jeudi que je comprends parfaitement
et je je vais te faire une proposition
tu nous dis ni oui ni non tu viens
clandestinement incognito passer une
nuit à alger tu vas voir ces gens de
l'armée de voir le gouvernement d'abord
tu voir le ministre de la défense or les
syndicats va tout ce qui compte
actuellement en algérie pour que donner
une idée plus plus réel plus concrètes
que ce que moi je peux te dire en une
heure arrivée à alger boudiaf consul
toute la nuit au petit matin sa décision
est prise il dit
la situation est dramatique
il accepte parce qu'ils pensent que sa
stature son histoire
sa capacité de rassemblement
lui permettront de jouer un rôle dans
cette transition est donc peut-être de
surmonter les difficultés qui pourraient
naître du pouvoir militaire où de telles
conneries au pouvoir donc je crois que
c'est ça c'est vraiment un
un patriote sincère et qui en même temps
peut-être des deux jurés des rêves
d'être le de gaulle de l'algérie on a
voulu faire un de ces un personnage qui
visiblement ils voulaient pas endosser
il le disait il n'était pas le sauveur
de l'algérie est pas de zorro il le
disait sommet vous même c'était vraiment
son message moi je suis là je vous
appuyez je crois avez-vous et sur vous
mais il n'y a pas de sauveur il ya plus
de soveria jamais une sauveur
[Musique]
carayon brujo assiette beau diable et le
désert at il dit et à part lyon à la
halle à l'étoile a la conviction de
boudiaf n'a pas changé il n'ya de salut
pour l'algérie que dans la modernité
pour restaurer l'état il faut que les
dirigeants ont regagné la confiance du
peuple il vient me se méfie
de la sécurité militaire et des gens qui
pourraient faire pression sur lui donc
il veut bien avoir des rapports normaux
avec un certain nombre d'institutions
interne mais il veut pas être prisonnier
d'un clan d'un groupe et donc qui
s'entoure d'anciens collaborateurs à lui
l'ancien du prs j'étais responsable des
discours de boudiaf
voilà il n'y avait pas de discours en
français à l'arabe l'arabe de boudiaf à
ce que la ram de boudiaf c'était un
arabe classique arabe populaire
dialectal et d'un peu de français dedans
donc un mélange à part les grands
discours qui l'a fait au début
particulier deux premiers c'est de
l'arabe classique où il lisait et encore
de temps en temps il avait des tendances
à vouloir sortir de son texte dix mille
la
doline la
salle
il
y croit ni
il avait été censuré par la télévision
c'est à dire qu'on avait on voyait bien
que son discours avait été montée on a
écouté des passages qui nous convenait
pas une c'est pâques donc c'était quand
même assez surprenant on faisait venir
ce cet homme qui ne demandait rien à
personne pour jouer le rôle de sauveur
de la nation après une espèce de deux
échecs politiques total est la première
chose qu'ils subissent et la censure de
ses propres services donc c'était
inquiétant pour l'avenir allez-vous
garder monsieur sy bergman rosalie comme
premier ministre ou bien estimez-vous
qu'il constitue encore un gage de
stabilité de crédibilité de l'algérie à
l'étranger ôté les classer dans l'hôtel
et je voulais dire reste au gouvernement
les rares humains ministériel
prochainement pour resserrer cette
équipe est de faire que c'est dans les
années à venir compte nous avons rien
contre contre tous les cadres de
l'algérie nous vous donnons seulement
trouver des équipes capables de travail
et changer le gouvernement c'est
lorsqu'on a un programme politique
alors moi j'avais compris sont en tout
cas mes camarades aussi bien c'est que
nous avions vécu père de transition
le gouvernement gère tous les dossiers
de l'algérie qui était lié à la gestion
quotidienne les dossiers sensibles et
est géré à la présidence
[Musique]
cette édition spéciale de la marche du
siècle ne recevra en effet qu'un seul
invité il s'agit de monsieur mohamed
boudiaf qui est président du haut comité
d'état depuis exactement deux mois
on en a marre des apprentis sorciers on
en a marre des apprentis sorciers dans
la politique des dinosaures du pouvoir
il faut du népotisme qui posent leur
frère comme ministres qui font de la de
la magouille qui pilent pays on en a
marre des apprentis sorciers religieux
qui disent qu'ils se prennent pour de
nouveaux prophètes alors qu'il ya un
seul prophète c'est moi mais n'y en aura
jamais d'autre tu vois il y en a marre
qu'on nous la fasse tout ces jeunes est
ce qu'on a mis de côté ses jeunesse qui
a été marginalisé et mon but c'est de
faire que cette jeunesse puisse
s'organiser autour de ces difficultés
être un élément de dialogue et un
contre-pouvoir
tant que ces sociétés de structures tant
qu'il n'y a pas des partis
représentatifs cette hargne jouera
l'europe y jouer et la révolte d'un site
soutien sur l avance des fils et parce
que les juifs aient supporté les erreurs
du politique tel que les événements de
4,8 que l'armée n'oublie pas
et ces cris et des conditions en algérie
ou s'enrichir
s'adonner à la corruption aux privilèges
c'est devenu quichotte man est l'exemple
viendront mais pas avec cette justice
semble quelque peu en faire mais je n'en
comptait dans son corps de jeu des gens
révoltés autant que celui de la rue et
qui sont décidés réellement à faire le
ménage des taux si nous allons les
préparer seulement je ne voudrais pas
que ce soit une
chasse aux sorcières au fond c'est un
appel à ce que vous fassiez le ménage en
avez vous les moyens pour l'instant
au début nous n'avons pas conscience qui
est en cause contre le monde mais très
vite
avec l'expérience que nous avions a eu
pendant les premières semaines les
premiers mois on sentait que ça résister
quelque part
et que par conséquent il ya d'un côté
des résistances qui pouvait être
efficace
qui pouvait être rapide et qui pouvait
être absolument fatal mais d'un autre
côté il y avait des potentialités
extraordinaires si le relais pouvaient
être créées elle pouvait contrer les
résistances et elle pouvait les balayer
c'est le relais avec la jeunesse avec le
peuple profond gelée par de la
corruption il m'a dit oui la corruption
mais
la corruption c'est un
c systémique des gens qui ont utilisé
leur position dans le pouvoir pour faire
des affaires et qui n'ont même pas eu la
décence
d'investir ce qu'ils ont volé au gagner
en algérie ils investissent en en
achetant des hôtels boulevard saint
germain ou en achetant des affaires aux
états unis ou au canada il n'est même
pas leur vol n'est même pas par
l'investissement à construire une
économie nationale boudiaf fait un tabac
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
à partir du moment où il a commencé
à parler de la mafia politico-financière
boudiaf a accepté de signer le texte
disant qu' il faut absolument que un
ancien général à la retraite soient
jugés pour corruption il a apposé sa
signature pour que un ancien juge à la
retraite soit jugé il a signé aussi la
décision d'arrêter de mettre en prison
et de juger hadj tout considéré comme un
symbole de trafic trans frontière mais
pour mener une action contre la
corruption il faut quand même un
appareil il faut une administration il
faut des magistrats il faut il faut il
faut mettre en place quelque chose une
machine à réprimer donc il faut le temps
et c'est ça qui n'a pas eu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le président et il y a eu des
critiques au sujet de l'utilisation des
mosquées à des fins à des discours
politiques et quel est le rôle que vous
envisagez pour la religion en politique
est ce qu'un projet de limitation voire
même d'interdiction comme dans d'autres
pays de l'utilisation de la religion à
des fins politiques
nous visons à travers la démocratie une
société égalité les sociétés modernes
sociétique s'ouvre sur l'extérieur une
société xul universel au lieu d'une
société qui va devoir d'état c'est
pourquoi nous pensons que la mosquée
dans ce domaine peut aider dans le
domaine des moeurs dans le domaine de
comportement dans le domaine dans divers
domaines à servir ces sociétés à ne pas
la discuter et l'islam n'a jamais
l'islam sunnite n'a jamais été pour des
extrêmes a jamais été pour le sens parce
que quand un type se prétend être un
musulman et qui se permet d'envoyer des
gens pour qu'ils d'autres jeunes de la
même nationalité ça ce n'est pas notre
histoire notre islam c'est l'islam la
tolérance notre islam c'est c'est
cette religion qui doit nous aider à
trouver à nous trouver nous-mêmes et
l'algérie l'algérie il est des choses
son islamité samar habitait sa berbérité
tout ça c'est le contenu de la société
ne voudront pas que l'arabité où la
vérité soit utilisée ou manipulé en vue
de diviser ce que nous sommes en état de
guerre subversive
est-ce qu'il faut employer les moyens de
guerre ou est-ce qu'il faut employer les
moyens de paix ce n'est pas tout à fait
la guerre classique mais c'est tout de
même une une guerre enfin maintenant une
force armée
terroriste
cinq
portraits étaient placardées dans les
mosquées avec condamné à mort par le
fils ce sont des tyrans et quiconque
exécute l'un de ces hommes ira droit au
paradis de veiller en recevant la presse
nationale parlait de dialogue national
est-ce que ce dialogue irait jusqu à
discuter avec le fils ou certains de ses
dirigeants actuellement prisonniers il
faut dialoguer avec les gens qui posent
le problème de la démonstration inter
médecins en termes clairs mais pas avec
des gens qui utilisent la mitraillette
et le reste et de deux je pense que le
syli à dialogue avec la société
algérienne qui constitue dans sa grande
majorité par la jeunesse algérienne j'ai
de pousser cette jeunesse à s'organiser
autour de ses difficultés à présenter
des programmes que je crois c'est là le
grand dialogue boudiaf quand il est venu
en algérie dans son esprit il n'était
pas venu pour combattre le fils sa
préoccupation ce n'était pas ça sa
préoccupation c'était l'algérie est en
crise le fils était un aspect parce
qu'après on l'a montré comme étant celui
qui est venu
son action pendant les six mois c'était
contre le fils mais pas du tout son
action s'inscrit dans un cadre beaucoup
plus globale et puis lui il était venu
pour débloquer une situation de crise le
4 mars 1992 sur plainte de l'armée
le front islamique du salut ais dissous
par le tribunal administratif d'alger
lorsqu'on a posé la question à boudiaf
et la répondu si j'ai bonne mémoire
effectivement il y a neuf mille détenus
dans les camps
s'il fallait en place et 20000 ou trente
mille je le ferai sans état d'âme parce
que je suis à un niveau il faut que je
restaure l'ordre entre 10000 et 15000
personnes détenues et les dangers que
court le pays
moi en poche rouge oui
je suis responsable et j'alterne ces
personnes il y a toujours l'inquiétude à
l'étranger sur les doigts de l'homme ici
il faut sauver la gym et ça ça passe au
dessus de toutes ces considérations
notre but c'est que si par exemple on
avait des possibilités
on aurait bien voulu que ça marche bien
que la société soit resplendissante ne
nous sommes devant un état de fait
contre lesquels il faut agir il faut
agir avec discernement
dans le cadre de cet incident je me sens
ni pour la répression ni pour dîner des
gens mais nous voudrions que notre pays
revienne à 7,1 un certain stabilité un
certain ordre de l'égalité et cela ne
peut pas se faire à peu tout ce qui a
été pendant sept ans dany et cela nous
sommes obligés de 2,2 supporter de
corriger eh ben on ne peut pas corriger
facilement comme ça ils jouissaient d'un
prestige personnel mais pas d'une
autorité légale j'allais dire émanant de
des urnes estimez-vous avoir une
manoeuvre assez large pour mener la
politique que vous souhaitez savoir que
je n'ai coudées franches
il y a eu pour effet de penser de tout
ce petit groupe qui travaille dans le
même sens et dans le but est de le
défier l'algérie et de les faire
dépasser cette situation que je dirais
un peu difficile il ne pouvait pas faire
abstraction de ce qui existait et de ce
qu'ils étaient les éléments du pouvoir à
la fois du pouvoir au sens de l'état au
sens de la gestion au quotidien donc du
gouvernement et aussi de tous les
éléments du pouvoir qui sont les partis
politiques ce qui en reste et du parti
unique le les larmes et les services de
sécurité les toutes les institutions
structures structure est du pays les
syndicats parce que le pouvoir on se
trompe quand tandis qu'en algérie le
pouvoir uniquement à tel endroit il est
diffus même si c'est très facile ensuite
de dire l'opacité permet de conclure que
c'est uniquement telle ou telle personne
qui tire les ficelles c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça même quand on a
envie de tirer les ficelles on le les
tirs qu'avec un minimum de consensus ça
c'est très important pour l'algérie ici
liée à sa culture et à ses traditions
passées tradition de parti unique ces
traditions profondes alors les clans
dans le pouvoir ils se regroupent
comment en algérie ils se regroupent le
plus souvent sur une base
régionaliste pas régionales mais
régionalistes c'est l'un des obstacles
majeurs à la construction de la
démocratie et à la culture de la
démographie et à la culture démocratique
dans la société pour faire évoluer ce
système boudiaf commence a formulé
l'idée du rassemblement patriotique
national le rpn qui doit permettre aux
forces vives du pays de s'organiser de
devenir le levier du changement qu'est
ce que vous allez dire à des jeunes qui
vivent à 10 dans une pièce qui nous qui
sont au chômage qui n'ont pas d'argent
et il y en a à chaque année comme vous
le savez beaucoup qui vont venir sur le
marché qui ne trouveront pas travailler
dans les années à venir c'est comment on
peut les convaincre qui va se passer
quelque chose pourquoi j'ai posé le
problème de la sab le mans démocratique
en main dans les songes je sais que j'ai
jonathan de tous et il dit c'est un
parti ou un mouvement qui va se créer et
qui va lui il fallait le créer
rapidement au mois de mai juin pour lui
permettre de préparer les élections
présidentielles mais pas comme un rôle
est uniquement quand même des béni oui
oui c'était conçu comme concevait
boudiaf le rôle du peuple le rôle du
peuple c'est une force pour coup pour
concrétiser un politique mais c'était
aussi lui le gardien du temple pas le
pouvoir c'était lui qui devait chaque
fois exprimé le réajustement tous des
petits partis et les grands partis et
certains leaders historiques qui
pensaient que peut-être c'était à eux
d'être là et non pas à lui d'être là où
il est installé dans siège de la
présidence ont commencé tout ça lui est
là cuisez de vouloir recréer les
phalènes de vouloir je sais pas quoi de
vouloir coiffé de vouloir diriger donc
et ce type d'accusation dans la
plateforme du rpn ya quelque chose qui
est absolument inouïe en tout cas
inhabituel pour la culture politique que
des algériens des trente ans
d'indépendance il y a le mot il faut que
les militants qui sont dans le deuil
dans le rpm fonctionne comme un
contre-pouvoir vous avez encore des
chips ainsi voter allez-y parce que je
vais arrêter parce que je pense que nous
avons fait le tour de toutes les
questions et jouer merci beaucoup et je
vous fixe rendez vous pour l'année
prochaine pour nous expliquer merci
beaucoup
comme on dit enfin l'a dit en arabe long
métrage aux râleurs est alors moi tout
de suite jeudi on repart chez nous
je me dis c'est pas facile
repartir c'est pas facile mais enfin
pourvu qu'on me laisse le temps et ça il
le disait toujours pourvu qu'on me
laisse le temps
parce que quelque part il savait que ça
arriverait d'ailleurs la veille de notre
tour il l'a dit il a dit ici il a dit je
vais rentrer mais je suis sûr qu'il est
qu qu'ils me tueront et quand je lui ai
dit c'est un essai c'est un suicide il
m'a dit non c'est le devoir pourvu qu'on
me donne le temps de faire quelque chose
[Musique]
les deux ouvriers repas de ses deux
rivales et sa magie c'est la famille al
chehri wager d'aristide ben ali a sans
doute at-il mali
boudiaf et reprend pour la première fois
et tournai de voyages à l'intérieur du
pays après cinq ans à la présidence il a
besoin d'un dialogue direct avec la
population il veut faire connaître son
projet de rassemblement en expliquer le
programme
[Musique]
pendant ses 166 jours
le pouvoir était crédible
et le pouvoir pouvait faire tout ce
qu'ils voulaient en direction de la
société et la société aurea terré
commencé à adhérer d'une manière très
forte il faut pas exagérer
là je dirais l'opinion favorable qu'on
avait de boudiaf à nadjaf c'est vrai
qu'il me toucher les gens déjà été
intéressé par son discours
mais
comme j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure le
fait qu'ils aient toujours le même
gouvernement que rien n'ait changé par
ailleurs enlevé un peu de crédibilité à
la nouveauté de son discours d'une part
et d'autre part cette venue c'est arrivé
ce discours nouveau coïncidait aussi
avec une phase de répression très forte
qui touchait beaucoup de familles c'est
rare dans l'histoire des peuples qu'il
est une rencontre entre un homme et son
peuple
moi je pense que l'algérie a une chance
c'est arrivé avec boudiaf excusez-moi de
l'émotion c'est un
et deux et pour ça
le combat de boudiaf continue
le 29 juin à annaba qui est pour lui une
ville test il saisit l'occasion d'une
rencontre avec les jeunes cadres et
chefs d'entreprise pour prononcer un
discours qui doit faire date
ça tout ça nous tous est
connu
mais
ne souffrait d' pour les fêtes n'a
d'échec
ça
un passager
dans son rapport la commission d'
enquête conclut nous sommes amenés à
considérer que là ça ça n'a pas agi seul
que derrière lui il y a des instigateurs
un groupe une organisation qui sont ils
c'est la question fondamentale
cette même commission se déjugera plus
tard et classera le dossier ont
officialisé la thèse de l'acte isolé
pour rct
un vieillard 73 ans qui était loin de la
réalité nationale
[Musique]
qui n'était au courant de rien donc il
pouvait l'utiliser ou le manipuler comme
il voulait mais ils se sont rendu compte
non seulement qu'il ne pouvait pas le
manipuler mais d'un autre côté
il a balayé tout ce monde et
je crois qu'ils ont pris peur quand il a
commencé de parler de corruption de
cette mafia ailleurs
d'ailleurs tout le monde l'a dit après
ses déclarations et ils ont dit je crois
qu'ils viennent de signer son arrêt de
mort et moi même je lui dis quand il les
a défiés à la télé
ceux qui l'ont tué en fait d'une pierre
deux coups peut-être même trois coups
il faut protéger leurs intérêts de deux
clans de gang de mafia
ils ont tué une possibilité
d'échappatoire d'alternative au système
politique que nous connaissons depuis
62 e qui est allé en dégénérant au fil
des ans
sera jamais regretté nous vivants on le
saura plus tard parce que l'histoire
découvrira des archives peut-être est
par contre la mort de boudiaf
aurait dû être une renaissance sans
faire de une renaissance c'est à dire un
démarrage politique ou une continuité
politique
l'assassinât a coupé court et évidemment
le sou son est revenue et le pouvoir est
devenu un pouvoir illégitime parce que
non crédible jusqu'à maintenant malgré
les élections malgré tout les élections
qu'on peut faire et bien le pouvoir n'a
pas reconquis
semblant de crédibilité les algériens
sont extrêmement sont de plus en plus
méfiants et n'ont jamais été aussi
méfiant que maintenant